sie schmuggeln menschen über den
ärmelkanal jetzt sind schleuser in einer
großen internationalen razzia im visier
auch hier auch in deutschland razzien
mit gsg 9 und sek in mehreren deutschen
städten
mitten in osnabrück sammeln sich am
dienstagmorgen polizeieinheiten aus
verschiedenen ländern ein
mehrfamilienhaus ist in ihrem visier die
beamten aus frankreich belgien
niederlanden und deutschland bereiten
sich zusammen auf eine stürmung des
objekts vor schwer bewaffnet und
vermummt dringen sie vor und reißen die
bewohner einer wohnung in einem
mehrfamilienhaus aus dem schlaf eine
neunköpfige familie mit sieben kindern
es hat heute morgen viele festen haben
in deutschland und anderen ländern
gegeben das ist bereits erfolgt jetzt im
anschluss erfolgen die durchsuchung der
objekte wir haben eben den verdacht dass
die schleuserbanden auch in deutschland
sozusagen in anderen europäischen
ländern unterwegs waren und hier suchen
wir letztendlich nach hinweisen beweisen
im bereich nautisches material aber auch
anderen indizien die eben diese unseren
verdacht bestätigen der vater der
gesuchte tatverdächtige ein mann game
zusammenhang mit einer großen
schleuserbande steht gegen die heute in
zwei bundesländern eine razzia
stattfindet vermummte beamte bringen den
mann aus dem objekt und führen ihn zu
einem polizeifahrzeug doch er ist nicht
der einzige tatverdächtige den die
polizisten festnehmen wie viele personen
ist derzeit unklar jedoch gibt es
durchsuchungen in niedersachsen und
nordrhein westfalen